new game with a static freak hmm let's  see if he's playing anything like the  name suggests that's the case he must  play G for this position oh it doesn't  or take on f7 in this position or 95  maybe he's thinking okay yes this is a  really crazy line of course um I forgot  how it is played Queen g6  well he did 495 maybe  not sure it all I know that in similar  positioned at least b5 is a serious  option it's not this position to put too  similar one did I go for this it's a  complete mess anyway  can I just take on e4 with the Queen now  what's what's the problem jack white  resigns  okay there is no problem okay adds it's  a totally unclear position I think also  I cannot analyze this right now what can  what can play I don't know whatever you  can play